strategy reference correctly strategy
sorry yeah from the city University of
New York talking about the effect of
restrictive interactions on epidemics
thank you thanks for the uh invitation
to present my work here
um I'm thankful to NSF for supporting my
research so my research is in the area
of probability and statistics and
mathematical modeling so
um
my thesis was in the area of epidemic
models particularly sis epidemic models
so after that I have been thinking of
how to address the question that if
there are restrictions to block
infection passages in different ways how
does it affect the regular infection
models like sis or sir
so uh and then whether we can have some
sort of causal inference based uh
associations or attributions that this
is the cause certain things are cause of
certain things Etc
so
um I have in this talk I have we'll I'll
talk about two different perspectives uh
from two different angles uh one is a
rigorous mathematical analysis of a
particular mathematical model which is a
variant of the contact process or sis
epidemic model where restrictions are
there and the other one is sort of more
exploratory that is ongoing right now so
that is uh from a bird's eye view what
what kind of restriction we can impose
in the outbreak of a pandemic and what
are the concerns if we can throw all of
them or at least most of them in the
bucket how does the model look like and
what are the things to uh aim at so that
is the second part uh third part I
wanted to but you know probably I'll not
have time so that's the causal
observational causal inference to
establish or not establish uh whether
certain measures like uh
masking measure or putting people at
home shelter at home measures they are
actually effective can we say from the
causal inference point of view in
statistics but that's that will be
different talk I can talk offline if you
were interested
okay so the first part is the joint work
with David sivakov and Matthew washer
from uh Ohio State so yeah
um
yeah and we are still working in other
areas
that's right so
this is uh the so the short overview is
that we first talk about what the
contact process is just to make sure I
probably all of you already know it but
just to make sure that everyone
knows exactly what I'm talking about uh
then I'll introduce a model which will
be studying the university is called the
contact process with avoidance I'll make
it clear what avoidance means and then
uh my our results are very modest
because there are a lot of you know a
lot of less techniques available so if
you invent techniques as well as you go
so uh we have results for Z the one
dimensional Line Cycles which are cycle
graphs and star graphs which are hubs so
those are the three places where we will
compare the results with the regular
contact process and see how those
benefits
okay so uh the contact process or the
sis epidemic model
is a particle system where uh it's like
a flu infection with a recurring
infection model where every vertex has
two possible States I or S infected or
susceptible
so uh infection State this is markovian
process so you know like many other
models it has many limitations but it
has been classically introduced as a
model for recurring infection and it has
uh attracted a lot of researchers in
mathematics in physics and other areas
for for research so the Dynamics goes as
follows that uh we use PSI a t to denote
process starting from an initial set a
at time t
uh and then this is a continuous time uh
Markov Markov process
each vertex has two personal States as I
said you can say zero or one one means
infected zero means susceptible so from
one state a Vertex goes to zero state
after uh
fixed uh mean amount of time the
distribution is exponential
but we can always normalize time
uh to make it uh have been one in this
case so then this is left with only one
parameter Lambda which is the infection
rate across each age so each Edge passes
the infection to the neighbor at Red lab
uh so Lambda is only parameter here
so pictorially you know if you start
with an infection one vertex then it can
you know try to infect its neighbors
separate Lambda and so on
and then it also the Infectious vertices
can get healed at rate one so there's a
computation between those two phenomena
like this this is an example
set of neighbors yes
so each age has infection rate Lambda so
that's why if we compute the rate at
which a particular vertex gets infected
its Lambda times the number of Neighbors
and are you assuming anything about the
degree distribution no no it's just on
the you know just on this line so far
yeah I'll come to the degree
distribution so
it's not available
okay so the main uh mathematical Tool uh
for studying this kind of processes is
called the Harris Construction which was
introduced by Harris or graphical
representation
where uh the space is in the x-axis
time goes up in the vertical axis and
for each element of the space the but in
the time axis we draw uh dots from
python process at rate one which
corresponds to the recovery dots
and the arrows uh are also for each pair
of vertices there's an arrow the arrows
are also followed by another independent
poisson process
with red Lambda so the arrows means that
the infection Trail follows the arrow
from tail to head
that's why there's error
so uh that that is sort of uh in some
sense of the probability space or in
some sense the basic structure on which
the process can be defined
so these personal processes are
independent and for the independent for
each pairs of Ages and for each vertex
so each vertex has a recovery person
process and each Edge has the infection
you know and for some processes so the
ages can be considered as directed or
undirected in this case will not have a
difference
now once such a construction is there
then we can Define the whole process the
contact process starting from any
configuration of zeros and ones below so
then we you start from suppose you have
a particular configuration of zeros and
one remember zero represents susceptible
one is infected uh so now start starting
from any set of ones we try to go up
follow the arrows to Branch out but we
are not allowed to cross any recovery
Dot
and if we fix a time here
and the set of at this time whatever
vertices you get as once which you can
reach From Below following this arrows
and without going across any recovery
dot will be one at that time will be
infected at that time
so that helps us to uh
construct
or couple
contact processes starting from
different initial conditions all at once
ah
one of the important properties of this
contact process there are many others
one of the important properties that I'm
going to contrast with the avoidance
process I'm going to be crucial is the
monotonicity property
so it is monitored in two sense that if
you have higher infections initially
that will then the distribution uh the
you know stochastically will have the
same or higher number of infections
later so more infections initially will
correspond to more infections later in
case of the contact process
course another monotoncity is the
infection if you have two different
infection rates one is smaller than the
other then the process corresponding to
the higher infection rate will have
higher number of infected vertices
certainly at times
so these are all in terms of
distributions but this can be
established using the
graphical constructions so basically if
you have more arrows that means if you
have more inflections the infection rate
is higher then you'll have you'll reach
more vertices at the top a higher level
at a later time T starting from the same
initial
by Time Zero on the other hand also if
you have if you have more once in the
button then you will reach out to more
people
so that is straightforward in this case
like for example if this particular
vertex status was zero here that's why
that becomes zero but uh if we had the
another configuration was uh one here
and that was the reason
your neighbor was one at the time
now uh the critical value so the one of
the important uh mathematical objects
for studying in these cases where things
are monotone is the critical value where
the behavior of the process changes so
in case of contact process the and
infinite graphs either uh
ZD or homogeneous tree etcetera in
shrink crops
the critical value can be defined as the
smallest value of Lambda for which uh
you have the infection stays on forever
with positive probability
or equivalently uh largest value of
Lambda for which the infection does not
stay on
the problem starting from Finance
now uh
classically a lot of study was there to
establish that Lambda C is non-trivial
numbers is positive and whether the two
whether there are multiple critical
values in terms of different kinds of uh
continuation of infection and so on so
it turns out that in case of straight
line
um the Lambda C is positive and
approximate values from simulations and
other numerical considerations is
approximately 1.65 around that time then
the exact value is you know it's not uh
it's not too close from solution
now uh when when uh
it turns out when we concentrate on
finite graphs instead of infinite graphs
then the notion of
the critical value is slightly different
because in case of finite graphs what
happens the process eventually dies out
the infection dies out that means
infection everyone becomes healthy
eventually
so uh it's a Markov process with an
absorbing state
so the same way you cannot Define the
critical value in this case we look at
the value uh the time of of Extinction
time the order of that
so if the extinction time is long then
we consider that to be a super critical
and if the extension time is small that
we consider to be sub critical now how
what is long what is a small depends on
the context uh from model to model it
varies so it turns out in this cases of
contact processes on finite graph long
corresponds to exponential or stretched
exponential
[Music]
um
Persistence of the infection and short
corresponds to logarithmic or poly
logarithmic
Persistence of infection
is the Lambda C unique or can there be
two different Lambda seeds so if you
define laminarsity with the way I Define
that's unique but in case of homogeneous
trees there are two different lambdases
because depending on the kind of
survival
there is a survival called strong
survival where a particular vertex keeps
on getting infected you know definitely
often
and the weak survival is where the
infection stays somewhere in the graph
so those two are different in case of
homogeneous trees but not in case of
lattices or you know so it's fertilized
okay thanks
now for example if you consider cycles
that are you know Taurus or these kind
of finite graphs uh it is well known
that when Lambda is bigger than same
Lambda C critical then the survival time
is exponential of daughter exponential
and very for example the expected value
the survival time is exponential in in
the size of the graph and uh when that
is
that is yeah
now the question was that next uh after
studying uh the contact process on
infinite graphs and finite versions of
infographs like porous and Cycles people
looked at random graphs
now there are different ways to
construct random graphs one is a few of
them which got very popular the
preferential attachment kind of models
where we have a sequence of growing
graphs where vertices come in and
attached to the existing vertices with
some rules proportional to the existing
degrees or some function of that that's
a
differential attachment model there's
also configuration model which uh where
people
choose a distribution first
and then choose the degrees from the
distribution B1 B to DN degrees for n
vertices subject to that the sum is you
know constrained to the that sum is even
so that it will have a valid graph and
then you do a random matching of the
half ages you can assign the DI mini
half figures to vertex I and do random
matching that's how we construct the
random graph uh you know the idea is to
have uh a uniformly chosen graph from
all collections or graphs having the
same proportion would be but there are
some variants of these options and not
the only way of constructing
now now the next question was the social
networks resemble this kind of graphs so
people are interested in how does the
product process behave in this kind of
social networks or internet networks
so these are there are different
approaches in 2001 and two around the
time people use minfield calculations
for studying both sir epidemic and says
epidemic models for sir epidemic models
they found that it has non-trivial phase
transmission the mental calculation and
it was like a population model on the
graphs for sis model also the result was
that if you follow me Midfield kind of
approach then depending on the
BP distribution exponents there are
phase summations are there maybe may not
benefit solution depending on what the
exponent gamma is when gamma is small
uh there's no first condition according
to the music calculation and then when
gamma is that there is uh 2005 a
Christian was one of the authors and
there are three other authors Berger
Chase and Sabri they first showed that
uh differential attachment model
equal to 3 has no critical value for the
contact process that means whatever
Lambda you choose the process can
survive for long time
so uh the main reason of the of the
argument was the behavior on the star
graph which is which I'm going to talk
about later also that the process sort
of uh the star graph sort of act as a
reservoir for the infection
and that's so that's enough to show that
and the since the contactless is
attractive in a sense they have a
monetary property if
can
die down
later on in my thesis I showed with
Professor duret that uh
not only on gamma it equals equal to
three it's true for any gamma bigger
than two and the exponential can the
court systems is almost exponential
important
yes in this case I mean meaningful
calculation is wrong with that also
right comment was made that the
physicists were wrong and I've seen Rick
talk about this and he was quite proud
of the fact that it's always
satisfactory for mathematician to show
the physicists that they're wrong
the only thing I can say is that if we
look at the metastable density uh the
Middle School density has it's like a
Lambda to the person power which grows
with Alpha so when Alpha is large it's
like it's like a power which sort of
goes to zero very slowly so you know if
you do simulation it's very difficult to
capture that that is positive or almost
zero
thank you
so uh
and then people have also looked at but
are there other cases where the meanful
characters is actually right like for
example Peterson looked at uh complete
graph with random weights in that case
indeed the contact process has a
non-trivial question
okay so now uh
next question was can we have
exponential is the maximum amount of
persistence as possible in these kind of
models so it was established for uh
configuration models
by first it was we showed the result
that is almost exponential but not
exactly exponential so first it was
improved by Mount floor
to show that this is exactly exponential
then other people have worked on
preferential attachment models
and then other parallel graphs with
exponent smaller than two because I
worked with smart actually bigger than
two
so uh recently there have been also
studies where people consider Dynamic
versions of the graph in particular
Dynamics where the dynamic is so fast
that it mixes very quickly so then uh
when the exponent gamma is bigger than
four exponential persistence is possible
to show and there's the first transition
there Lambda C is positive
very recently uh Shankar vamidi alanslai
and some others their students and
colleagues have shown that uh the degree
distribution has a role to play in
determining whether there is a first
sanction or not in particular if the
degree distribution has an exponential
moment that's if a necessary sufficient
condition for
having uh numbers a positive or not so
Lambda 6 is positive if and only if the
deputy student has exponential moments
it doesn't then
this is for configuration models yes
uh no there's a there are subtle
differences in industry
and this is only for the Lambda one the
smaller critical value for the trees
so so this means any power
so in particular this doesn't just mean
gamma because in three or two it needs
any power law will have Lambda C equals
zero right yeah
that was already shown before uh that I
my result showed it for a gamma bigger
than 2 for gamma less than two there was
a con I think was
problems
but this was a more stronger version of
the result saying that uh that's the
finding the necessary sufficient
condition for existence
existence of sorry first submission this
explanation
okay so now uh
I come back to the avoidance question
now suppose
uh I decide to avoid my friend if I find
out that my friend is infected
temporarily until my friend gets healthy
so then how does it change the Dynamics
that's the main question the question
so here uh only s i combinations have
this uh extra addition like avoidance so
there's a parameter Alpha to it so if I
choose to if I get to avoid before the
infection is sent to me then the
infection is not sent to me even at
least for that particular period
so that uh we can think about that
that's an interest intuitive it should
reduce the infection in the whole
process and or in terms of critical
values it should increase the critical
value so now let's see what happens so
this is a you know pictorial and this is
was initially introduced into physics
literature I think uh it has been in
multiple papers
there now there is no only one way to
decide decide which model to choose
because
you can avoid but then when you come
back when you re-establish the contact
it's not there's no one way like you can
wait for a random amount of time and
then again you estimate the contact
or you can wait till your you yourself
become healthy so that you know you
don't want to go to your friend when
you're infected Etc there are different
variants of this so different uh
papers have addressed this this
direction different variants empirically
So you you're avoiding a friend who is
infectious who you know has symptoms or
how do you know if if the friend is
infected today you wouldn't know that I
wouldn't know that so that's why there's
a competition between the infection and
the avoidance
so if I get to know before the infection
is passed to me then only I can avoid
otherwise not
otherwise the infection will come to me
anyway
okay so I'm not instantaneously I'm
understand I'm getting the knowledge
that my friend is infected only when
sort of based on symptoms or other
information or friend telling you or
something it's like my uh
attempt to stay away from infected
trades individual account it's not that
someone is a government is announcing
that these these people are infected not
like that so it's like individual level
uh attempts yes
Alpha is a problem
and a means activation of the edges so
when I say so d and a means deactivation
activation like and at what rate do they
have uh so the activation happens at
Alpha and uh so then these papers have
different versions that's why you know I
want to clarify that the activation some
papers have considered activation rates
are separate parameter beta for example
uh but some some authors have said that
activation will be automatic when people
both are healthy
but some people say that one of them is
healthy so there are different versions
of that so the deactivation there is one
parameter so I'll in the next slide I'll
specify which particular model we have
results on so we have deactivation uh
rate Alpha One parameter activation we
don't have any other parameters
exponential time
so this is still markovia so I put these
two
okay
now uh the if you get the age gets
deactivated then I does not pass on the
infection to S so I becomes s on its own
if there is no other you know there's no
other influence then I becomes on its
own
healthy and stay there
this is called temporary reactivation
now this is the model that we study
rigorously where uh as I said that Alpha
is the rate at which the activation
occurs
so now the contact process was only on
the vertices now you have to consider
both vertices and edges
so vertices are one zero one means
infected zero means susceptible or
healthy for ages one means
activated zero means deactivated
and then the Dynamics are uh is sort of
it's a mixed Dynamics it influences each
other so the vertex Dynamics is similar
that once it gets once a Vertex gets
infected the data treated gets held is
rate one you can normalize time so that
you have that and then infection across
each Edge is Lambda like before
and then the alpha is a new parameter
which is uh the avoidance rate
so if Alpha is very large then you are
quickly recognizing that your friend is
infected here you'll be safer sometimes
okay so is the model clear any questions
it's okay
okay now uh this is the graphical
construction so we need more ingredients
to uh represent the model initially we
just needed the recovery dots and the
arrows but we now we need a block titles
and also we need a region which is sort
of avoided regions so block Terror means
that that corresponds to the poisson
processor great Alpha so again recovery
dots were for each vertex vertical line
has recovery dots percent process rate
one
now we consider only directed graphs
because you know who is blocking whom is
important
so so we consider directed graphs and
for each directed Edge I have a percent
process Lambda where the infection goes
from tail to head
and then uh
for each pair ordered pair WV of of
Neighbors
if there is a blocked arrow that means
that if W was infected V was healthy V
is blocking the injection to come to the
to V from w
so infection is blocked from tail to
head again
and once the infection is blocked then
we stay until the infected person is
getting healthy and instantaneously the
block is removed
so in the classical in the graphical
construction all the infection arrows
that that falls between two cons you
know between a blocked arrow and a
recovery dot is sort of ignored
while constructing the process
so you immediately get
helps so
you get immediately unblocked when you
get healthy yeah that version we have
studied it's not the only version as I
said but that version will start
like any other parameter also that you
know we can use that but that will make
the model more complicated
so as long as the infected person as
soon as the infected person is healthy
the infection is that block is moved
okay so uh the main difficulty as I was
saying is that uh lack of monotonicity
property in this case like for example
here is an instance of uh the same sort
of structures in terms of arrows and
dots
but in the left hand side you just have
one infection
so infected individual at time zero and
the right hand side I have two
but uh in the at time T at a later time
we have more infections here than there
why is that so the infection this is
just an instances there are many ways it
can behave like that so the infection
from starting from here it travels in
these arrows and goes to here and then
comes back and so that's why uh you have
these two what is infected at at this
time because it you have an infection
trail that avoids the recovery dots
but on the other hand if this vertex was
infected to begin with then this vertex
is avoiding this vertex this is because
of this blocked Arrow
so this this remains until this vertex
is getting healthy at this point so as a
result these two infection arrows this
infection arrow is sort of ignored
and because of the ignore ignoring some
of the infection arrows so you get less
infection here
so that doesn't mean that the process on
an average is monoton or not but the
highest construction coupling doesn't
work
that's a big impediment and you know
it's challenging this you know studying
this model
um
now we also
that's why we have two different uh
critical values here we cannot say they
are equal conjecture that they are but
uh we don't have a proof yet so in case
of straight line for fixed Alpha
positive we Define Lambda Alpha minus to
be uh the infimum of all lambdas for
which you have how is the infection
persists for every positive probability
starting from finite sales
and we Define Lambda Alpha plus to be
the critical value below so that which
is the Supreme overall Alpha all sorry
all Lambda for which the process in the
infection dies down infection everyone
heals with probability one
so in case of contact process Lambda
Alpha minus and plus are the same but in
case of this we cannot say there's some
yet because we don't have monitor
density
but if they are ordered Lambda Alpha
minus is smaller than Lambda Alpha Plus
so the first result that one of the main
reasons that we have shown is that the
change in Alpha the as a function of
alpha they are linear they are not they
are bounded by two linear functions
so they're not uh growing like a square
or something
okay now uh in case of
cycle graphs the same uh similar results
as we we have for
regular contact processes hold
qualitatively but for this value of
Lambda C that if Lambda is large
compared to linear function of alpha
then you have supercritical behavior
that the process survives for
exponentially long time
and if Lambda is small compared to
linear function one plus Alpha then the
plus is dragged out
so the same constants whole Heroes same
bounds
is the same only thing is that the
critical value Lambda C is moved
linearly as a functional valve
now in case of hubs that was the main
reason for uh you know the contact
versus having no critical values in the
bbcs nutrition's paper was that the
contact process if you restrict on a hub
it survives for exponentially long time
for all positive land
so on the contrary here
as soon as Alpha is positive
the survival time in our order boils
down to a polynomial survival time
it's very exponential not only that we
can compute exactly the exponent
depending on Lambda and Alpha
which should capture the Persistence of
the infection so this Delta is is in
terms of basically an eigenvalue of a
certain
generator of a contact continuous time
Mark of chain so it turns out to be this
expression
and it's correct up to little of one
correction
here in case of hubs the behavior is
drastically different because it drops
down from exponential to polynomial as
soon as Alpha is positive okay
so Delta is basically uh one over gamma
where gamma is a next slide will be
clear Delta is one over gamma where
gamma is an eigen value of a Associated
Mark of continuous time Mark of operator
which Mark of a parade right no that
will be clear in the next slide in the
proofs okay I'll describe that okay yeah
just wait yeah I see
yeah
would you expect Lambda C to be positive
if Alpha is positive that's the
configuration model so for the
configuration model our guess is that it
will persistence time will be either a
polynomial or stressed exponential but
we are not sure which one is true
because we don't have monotonicity
that's why we cannot combine the
activities of the stars and say you can
because stitching stitching together
requires monopronicity argument that's
what is missing it so far
so what do we you know it seems like
either of those two will be okay
okay but definitely it will be less than
exponential n which is the case but for
regular contact us
okay yeah so that's a question that I
have there what next uh that that is
showing the task
um
we expect either n to the order of one
or exponential little of n right if you
piece together but uh we don't have the
one to answer yet
also there are other questions here we
just we only consider the model where
individual interest is to protect uh him
or her from infected frames but if there
are collective uh decisions or
Collective societal movements or
societal uh
approaches then that particular models
will have different behaviors
so the difference is that in the
individual attempts you are saving
yourself on saving your cell phone
you're not telling your friend's friend
that you know that that person is
infected but in case of moreover social
Society you'd expect you'll tell all
your other friends of that or you tell
your friend to tell his or her friends
that currently
the person is infected so that
they can go home temporarily and survive
experience it
so the only the avoidance strategy is
just to avoid that person but not
necessarily to wear a mask when you are
around that person just stay away from
them yeah so so other strategy can be
that if I see my friends and say that
please go home temporarily uh otherwise
your infections or something like that
something or that of the router Okay so
or that also depends on social awareness
how important you feel is that there are
you know different
variants from that perspective but you
know I'm not going to bear
in this molecule but that's something to
consider in the future
okay so now uh let me quickly give some
uh the proof ideas
uh in case of
a straight line and the graph the cycle
graph when Lambda is smaller than Lam
one plus Alpha we managed to bound it by
a biased random work with a negative
drift of the right most on the leftmost
for the right most negative grid for the
most positive derivative
there are a lot of technicalities
involved so I'll not go into the details
of it but that's the Crux but there are
lots of dependent structure here because
of the particular dynamics that is
introduced
so that creates lots of dependence which
is unavoidable
so the construction is a non-trivial but
I don't have to go into the
technicalities here
uh for the other direction when
Lambda is large compared to Alpha
then uh we use some version of the
what's called block Construction in
oriented percolation case so we divide
the space time into blocks of this form
where four vertices are there and some
time Tau
so time tau is such that whatever the
configuration is with some Infected
vertices eventually we have all
infective vertices and all ages all ages
active
so if that happens we call that block
good block
so the idea is that if you have a good
block then the infection passes through
it to the next level
and we show that if Lambda is large
compared to a linear function of alpha
then
a block is brewed with high probability
independent of all the interference
coming from its neighborhoods because
it's very highly dependent
structures because of the interference
once we establish that then we can
compare with a well-known structures
which is called oriented percolation uh
which which sort of has the property
that uh if the oriented percolation has
its site has probability P of being open
and 1 minus P are being closed if p is
close to one then the you can have an
infinite path using open vertex system
only
you can compare that with that and so
the infections are persists for long
time forever in the increasing infinite
graphs and in case of Cycles
the infection process for exponentially
long time because this sort of pushes
the infection uh upward when it sort of
shrinks down to small
so it has a locally positive drift
yeah as I said that uh there are lots of
dependents and then that cannot be
ignored here so the bound has to be
deformed irrespective of what happens in
the outside world that's why the
construction of these blocks are very
very crucial
so okay now I come to the star graph and
the question of the Markov chain that I
promised so in case of star graph the
behavior is uh
the following that the when the center
is infected versus so the center is not
infected there are two different
Dynamics when the center is infected
Center is one
then the leaves they follow each of them
follow a Markov Markov process
continuous time Markov process with
generator given by this where the states
are combinations of 1 0 and a d a means
active d means reactive for the ages
that is linked to the hub
and one zero corresponds to the
infection status of the vertex there are
four possible States then infection
status two possible values and the
states of the age two possible values
all to the first four states
so each leave the status of each leaf
we have like a mark of continuous time
Markov chain on this fourth state
and when the center is uninfected
healthy then it uh sort of there's a
uniform where decreasing uh of the
number of infected needs but it's not
much it just decreases by order one by
geometric amount of number
but the the time it takes to decrease it
always tries to push infection to the
center so that once the center gets
infected it tries to push the infection
again for the leaves go you know
increase and so on so the way the
infection which is different from the
contact process is the following that
because of this Markov Behavior
at any time T after let's say if the
infections phase stays for infection
phase for the center stays for T amount
of time
then at the end of it you have on an
average approximately n times e to the
power minus t uh gamma T amount of
leaves that are left where gamma is the
gamma is the largest eigen value of the
operator for the negative of that
so now if this becomes less than one
then basically there is no infected
leaves at all
so that's the time that you know when so
we have to wait till we have a large
infection time for the center
so the the probability that you have a
large infection time for the center is
polynomial is small so you have to wait
for a newly long amount of time
to have a large infection thing for the
center and during that all of the leaves
goes down to you know vanishes or goes
down to healthy status the infection
advantages
so that's why we get uh
polynomial persistence here as as
opposed to exponential where this
behavior is absent in the continent
foreign
to show uh what happens in case of cycle
graphs synthesis so this is the alpha
axis
this is a heat map
Alpha axis Lambda axis
and for each combination of Alpha and
Lambda we have done independent
simulations for I I don't divide for
probably 100 times of the process
starting on a cycle of length let's say
n n equal to 1000 I guess
and I looked at the proportion of time
of the situation proportion of
iterations the process arrived for a
long time so we Define long time
beforehand which is between polynomial
and exponential something called uh
something uh something linear which is
between sorry logarithmic and
exponential
so if uh the process survives Beyond The
Times They have counted that as a
success and then we have plotted the
proportion of successes here so when
Lambda is small Alpha large that means
most of the cases the process dies out
this the same corresponds to that and
the other end corresponds to the
situation where Lambda is large Alpha
small then most of the cases the process
doesn't die out so the boundary is in
between which is like a linear function
where
things gradually grow from black to
white and there are great regions here
so it seems that it's maybe indeed the
Lambda is an function of satellite
function
okay uh questions
so that's the end of this portion
uh now I go to the next version as I
said the expression is exploratory this
is ongoing work with uh but Mishra uh
of a student in NYU uh this is more like
a bird's eye if you uh and then at the
initial stages outbreak of a pandemic
what kind of
aspects
can be considered from you know one
perspective there are of course not only
one person there are so many different
perspectives but this is just one
so
uh when pandemics uh with highly
contagious disease breaks out where
people are dying because of the
strength of the you know
injections and also there are many
people who are carrier without knowing
so there are asymptomatic carriers then
ideally you would like to test everyone
frequently before letting them out
letting them you know out of in the
street or interacting with others going
to schools or office or you know going
to shops Etc
but that itself may be very difficult to
do you know because of different
constraints impediments cost is
definitely one constraint people not
agreeing and there are thousands of
constraints that can create problem for
testing people frequently
so there no so one possible way to
tackle this is that to have sort of uh a
badge system
so depending on and then doing the
testing in a in a batch like a pull
testing scenery
so the badge the idea is that once you
have a green badge for example that sort
of a green light that you can you are
free to move without any restrictions
and you know you can think about
multiple layers of different badges
depending on how many access you want to
Grant I have in this case just used
three uh green orange and red
so red meaning that you have your your
test has been tested positive
so you know because on the policy you
can be asked to stay at home for you
know for the time being or you can have
very limited access just to you know
have basic survival needs and so on that
depends on the policy of course again
and Origins are in between that we don't
know since we are doing pool testing so
we are not sure whether you're Greener
rates or somewhere in between so you
have limited access
now what are the uh
ways that you
you can possibly
uh transfer from green to Ray orange and
orange to red and how does it work so so
you do this testing in a fixed so think
about the scenarios particularly in
underdeveloped countries where there's
not not much resources also so there are
some fixed test centers or
uh places where where they can do pool
testing
so once your pull test is the pool size
is also a parameter so if you have more
resources you can reduce the pool size
even to one but if you don't have
resources then you know you have may
have to go for
higher pool sizes particularly under
developed countries where they have many
people
uh you know highly populated
underdeveloped countries
pool sizes uh is there and then there
are a number of pools and you go to one
of the pools once the test is if the
quotas is positive you keep on having
your green status if your pull test is
negative your status is downgraded to
Orange and from Orange you will
downgrade to red
now
then people will and then once you have
of course rate then you'll have
restricted movement so people will come
back to test again for the next full
test to see whether they have uh changed
you know because of the because it
happened not because of that person but
others participating in the full test
but how do you downgrade from Orange to
Red if you have more people in the pool
no if we test positive
if if you're originally orange it it's
positive
but from green to Orange also is
positive right yes
so this is your basically you know
downgrading by one level okay okay fair
enough
and then once you test negative from
both green uh orange and red you'll go
back to green because you have this
negative Infinity
uh but then you can control the rate at
which you are testing so if a person has
a green
badge uh you know then that that person
can test more frequently
than a person at the rate if you have
red badge you can ask that you have to
come back two days after for example
dot now you cannot do immediately he
cannot jump again
and then uh in terms of
so now what happens to the what is the
difference between the different badge
holders they have limited accesses to
the interactions vary between different
importance
so okay so now uh
it sort of gives rise to uh sorry do we
know what color of badges other people
have like if I have green batch do I
know Christian has right or no you don't
know others so it will not affect how I
interact with other people like it's not
gonna tell me who is safer to interact
with streams so it's a because of
security uh and privacy is only you are
you also know your status okay okay
but the full test is like whoever is
arriving it's like you can think about
as a random collection from the
population that is coming to the pool
tests and like before going joining a
class or you know going to office
so now this is this gives rise to uh
line compartments instead of three so
um or you consider sir model in this
case so an sir model and also there's
another thing to consider is the
structure of the interaction so there
can be a graph structure like that's
most likely there will be realistically
that there are local interactions more
and then as you go far apart the
interactions decreases but for this
uh simulation study I just have
considered only complete graphs so there
are nine possible combinations of them
and then the the transition between them
depending on several parameters
so one parameter has one set of
parameters let me just describe the set
of parameters
yeah
yeah
if I'm recovered why do you care about
patch I have
uh no so it's like you can go you're
going back to your household you're
staying with the household right so
don't know I don't know who are you
staying with there but I'm recovered in
your Sr model if I if you put all the
recovered States if you collapse them it
just will not change will do that so it
just will not affect them
yeah so the parameters in this case are
so first of all the state space can be
described as d sub b d is a disease
status B is the batch
so 3 cross 3
and then
uh the parameters can are there the rate
at which you are testing
then uh
the freedom which is how frequent you
are allowed to go which is a fraction uh
so and then V10 gamma are the original
parameters of the sir model beta is
infection rate gamma is recovery rate
and if a badge there's a green badge
will have freedom Phi of G orange badge
will have freedom fee of O and red badge
you'll have freedom C of R so these are
fractions between zero and one so if you
have a fraction it's a number between 0
and 1 strictly then it essentially
reduces the interaction of that group
with others
so for example if you make it to zero
then you are basically establishing
quarantine that you are not allowed to
implement at all you have zero freedom
and there are other parameters also like
for example if the test is developed
recently it's not well guaranteed to
have uh nice results it can have false
positivity rates false negativity rates
the cool size is another question that
also has to roll a play a role in the
overall uh you know cost sorry which
which parameter is accounting for the
specificity sensitivity of the test or
the efficacy of the test which one both
of them okay both of them can be there
okay thanks and then but uh there are
different roles for them they are not
exchangeable though because if a test is
false negative that has one rule but if
it is false positive that sort of
amplifies things also because it sort of
means that more people will go into
quarantine and then you know that can
increase the corresponding cost of
quantity
and again other parameters from the pool
sides Etc so like pool size can also
vary uh depending on the constraints
size number of pools can also be there
and also you know it can be a closed
Society where people are not going out
mostly or it can be you know like New
York City or some big cities where
people are sort of constantly rolling in
then the constants are different
uh then the prevalence rate also you
know may have discontinuous maybe a
discontinuous functions also
so this also can be you know if we have
this pool testing data available
at the aggregate level then you can also
estimate the
um
this is prevalence from there if there
is a you know sudden jump because of
some super spreading event or some new
strains Etc that also can be tracked
okay so uh now there are different
questions that can be asked so I have
done some simulations here some
indications I haven't done in theory yet
that's to to do uh so
so this is a simulation of the another
simulation that the if you solve the ode
is numerically
uh and then I have here nine figures I
shouldn't have so many but let me just
quickly say what happens so the left is
the all line OD is I'm plotting
the right is the one which is combined
is an INR only
if the first row I have no restrictions
that means uh all the testing rates are
equal all the freedoms are equal
in the second row I am keeping testing
rates equal but I am reducing freedom
for orange and red and for example I'm
reducing the weight to zero so that is
our quality
and the third row uh I have both
um
reduction of
freedom and reduction of testing weights
so overall I you know it says that if
you do if you grow from the upper to the
lower levels the infection is suppressed
so and then you can control these
parameters this you have this fee fee
parameters and the T parameters to make
it super critical also very you know
also
but of course it comes with the cost if
you if you do it like this then yeah
basically you may end up doing
quarantining many people who are
actually not influenced infected
so there's a quarantine cost for that so
now how much Freedom will be there it's
also an interactive parameter it can be
thought about as interactive parameter
and then depending on the prevalence you
can adjust that if you want to run a
scheme so if you give people longer
essentially denying Freedom yeah even
lockdown for longer everyone goes to
goes to you know yeah
infection right away it was not yeah
sustainable because of the other
economies but the disease doesn't
rebound right it stays at zero basically
yeah it doesn't come back up again yeah
okay but you can the advantage here is
these are flexible this
once you see the other super splending
event or something that the prevalence
has gone up you can you know tighten
things for it or something
we have restrictions and then you can
relax it gradually so this is like a
framework for you know doing all these
different things
so but uh the next thing is that the ode
doesn't answer all all the questions so
for example one of the question is that
uh since we're doing pool testing
there's always be chances that even if
I'm not infected I can my test comes uh
positive which is I consider it to be
false positive I can be wrong
um
against authorities who are doing the
test saying that you know I'm
I have no symptoms and nothing but
you're saying that my test is positives
I'll not agree to his system so then we
need to know what's the average time or
expected time to to get back the right
badge color so in fact it gets weighed
uh and non-infected gets green patches
so before that so this those questions
cannot be answered from the OD model so
I have also we have also studied some
the agent based version of this model
where individual uh players are acting
According to some markovian boots also
here
um
and then we computed over different
iterations we computed the average
number of time it takes to get the right
batch
and we plotted against pool size so it's
it's questions yeah
so normally when I think of Agents I
think of this complicated systems where
every agent has their own strategies
their move and stuff
isn't this just the stochastic version
of your ode model you're studying here
where you just have each vertex has nine
types and you have some transition rates
and so in principle for example I could
probably study the burst process
calculate the largest eigenvalue and
predict I'm not right no yes
analytically I did it yeah that should
match with this probably but I did it we
did it like we have a bunch of different
people in this
in the community and they are following
their rules what they are supposed to do
I see but you're a mathematician so you
could calculate look at the nine by nine
Matrix and try to find the largest
eigenvalue yeah but if there might be
difficult the difficulty is there
because there are the interactions are
highly only needed so that's why whether
linearization will be a good idea I'm
not very convinced yet so because
yes that that kind of no you can use the
Next Generation operator method to find
that but can you convince me again why
do you say the OD system will not
um always goes for the limiting Behavior
right how does behaving the long run
proportions
but I'm asking for an individual person
how much time I have to wait till I get
a first right correct badge okay because
if that is too long people will not
agree to this you know
we should ask our mathematicians here
but wouldn't we wouldn't we expect
wouldn't we expect uh law of large
numbers even for this
so so the sod is here it's nine okay
there are nine states instead of three
but we can still write down a stochastic
system and shouldn't just the general
kun's message just work and give us an a
law of large numbers or maybe your
method if it's not but your your times
are exponential right so probably it's
it's just stand out
yes it converges to this ode no yeah the
only thing is that the interact the
rates actually they are very highly
laundry
they involve rational functions and so
on
and so on highly non-linear
that's why I'm not sure whether that
will give the right oh yeah can you go
back twice the rates are non-renewed
yeah
so these are just rates now can you go
back to wire rates non-linear so there
are in terms of the parameters I'm
saying there are different
no no there are other parameters like
tgpf all these fees are there then false
positivity rates are there and then pull
size is there so if you consider all of
them this is highly non-linear rates
but it's still a linear mock Markov
chain right
oh I mean it's just it's it's memoryless
it just has rates it's so it's just a
finer dimensional system with rates it
will have a law of large numbers and you
could even study the behavior of a
single person that still is within the
methodology of the standard law of lot I
mean it's more or less done by kuns
already right
this question can be answered no so
that's more of a comment so so you
certainly could and there is even a way
in which you could try to sort of induce
this limiting mean field probability
measure and then study how it differs
from the original system so there are
ways in which you can try to do this
okay
certainly possible yeah I'm happy to
learn uh because I I was a little bit
bogged down because I want to real
rational functions that I'm getting but
I'll be happy to take
sure
you get your solution tomorrow okay come
to the talk tomorrow
similar
for a simpler one simpler the same idea
yeah yeah so come to the talk tomorrow
yeah sure I'll be here
but the other hand that the pool size
increase if the pull size increases then
the total number of infection reduces
that's uh probably intuitive because if
you have more pool size then a lot of
people will be asked to quarantine for
the time being
foreign
look at the cost from the cost
perspective which strategy is a good
strategy in in this framework then good
strategies are low cost strategies that
the cost has different components
one is the cost of quarantining people
if you are quarantining people then of
course they are work hours have been
lost so
you have to content the you know you
meeting the authorities may have to
compensate that person's in some way so
that that has a cost itself so you
cannot you don't want to quarantine
people too many too much because that is
C2 is the other way the on the other
hand the cost due to spreading on the
infections this is health related costs
fatalities uh you know long uh
sufferings and Etc
and then these all these all of them
depends on the particular parameter in
this framework so this can be a function
of these things
so there are two other costs which is
overhead cost
and the other one is
you know for the testing so if you have
more test budgets you can as you have
seen the morning talks today that
there's a test budget depending on that
you have to plan accordingly we have
unreated test budget then
it's a different story so now if you
combine all these costs and then
what we found out in the simulation
study at least is that initially that
the uh the cost is not a monotone
function of any of the parameters
so for example the full size also the
for certain cost structures the pool
size also uh can you know the optimal
pool size can also be not one but
something bigger than one
yeah so now the this this framework can
also be used as I said for detecting
whether there is a certain surge uh and
then if you have a good idea about this
cost so one you know a huge amount of
effort is needed for understanding how
much the cost is per person or you know
well that's another cost also to overall
economy yes supply chain collapse of
economies you know they have this kind
of big outbreak of terrible disease yeah
so
then once you have the total cost idea
then you can choose the right parameters
and you have a freedom of adjusting them
so that you know your cost is same then
you may have to have other objectives
like optimizing other trial business
okay so this is the framework I had so
yeah thank you excellent thank you
thank you excellent presentation uh any
questions any more comments I know we
ask you so many questions yeah
so in which case let's thank you one
more time
[Applause]
very nice um next talk or is it now or 3
30.